Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number
which is 219 to David P Karen called in
upset that I'm triggering her dogs now.
I don't use the term Karen generically.
A viewer named Karen. I want to be clear. People
might write in and say, David, I thought you said
you didn't use that term because it's a racialized
term. That's completely correct. The caller's name
is literally Karen. Take a listen.
Speaker 3:
Hi, David. This is Karen from Texas.
Speaker 2: And we loved what she showed
me and my husband. But would you please.
Speaker 3: Stop bumping your microphone?
It set my dogs.
Speaker 2: Into a.
Speaker 3: Frenzy. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I sometimes
become so agitated in my gesticulation that I
will hit the microphone and I don't do it on
purpose. I know that, particularly for people
listening with certain headphones. It very,
very much is a problem. So I apologize. Karen,
on today's bonus show, I am going to give you the
rundown of my upcoming appearances, including with
Lex Freedman, Patrick, Bette, David and Anthony
Pompliano all coming up between now and the end
of the month. Technically, February 1st, I guess
Pat producer Pat actually had a complete
breakdown of his Internet connection. And
today's show is being produced in a coffee shop
Producer Pat just ordering double espresso after
double espresso to be allowed to stay. It's
crazy what's going on. I'll tell you about it
on the bonus show as well as about my upcoming
appearances. Get instant access to the bonus
show by signing up at join Packman dot com.
Speaker 2: The bonus show where you want
to make money? Yep. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Money is being made on
the bonus show. That's exactly right,
Alex. Thank you. We will see you on the bonus
show. We'll be back tomorrow. It's a great week
of programing. And of course, the town hall is
Wednesday at 6 p.m. Eastern. And make sure you've
slammed that subscribe button on YouTube, pushing
us ever closer to 2 million YouTube subscribers.